à 300 km au nord du cercle arctique
canadien aujourd'hui on peut ressentir
un peu de chaleur
pour la première fois depuis le début de
la pandémie la communauté de toc toc toc
se rassemblent des retrouvailles
attendues depuis longtemps dans ce petit
hameau nordique isolé de tout
tout en célébrant la fin des mesures de
confinement il ya quand même d'autres
préoccupations dans la communauté toc
toc toc et la communauté qui est situé
le plus au nord des territoires du
nord-ouest
ici c'est un l'océan arctique la
frontière du canada avec la russie est
depuis des décennies si on perd de
l'importance de mieux surveiller et de
mieux protéger cette frontière saône
il y a à peine 2000 kilomètres qui nous
séparent de la russie dit le maire de
toc toc toc
toc
même si la communauté de 860 habitants
est à majorité et nous via louit presque
tout le monde a du sang russe dans les
veines à cause des chasseurs de caribou
et des baleiniers de toutes origines qui
louent au hasard des déplacements de
leurs proies se sont retrouvés à passer
par ici notre choix des menus à launois
watch j'ai moi même du sang russe
j'espère seulement que ce n'est pas le
sens de poutine dit il de
bonne
méthode toyota et surtout un endroit
stratégique pour la surveillance de
l'article le norad il ya installé
pendant la guerre froide ce site de
radars qui fait partie du système
dallaire du nord ce système compte en
tout 47 station de radar à court et à
longue portée répartis dans le nord du
canada l'ensemble système de détection
et de radars qu'on avait mis en place
par la guerre froide tombe en désuétude
en ce moment des avions russes
pourraient larguer des missiles
balistiques contre le canada dans leur
propre espace aérien on aura aucune
capacité de détecter le gouvernement
canadien a récemment octroyé un contrat
de plus d'un demi milliard de dollars
pour l'opération et l'entretien de ces
radars mais ça prendra bien plus ça veut
dire ça le prend des nouveaux radars ça
prend des nouveaux des nouveaux
satellites ça prend des nouveaux
senseurs ça prend des drones qui ont pu
se déployer dans le nord
ça prend des nouvelles bases c'est un
investissement de entre 5 et 10 millions
de dollars 1 150 km au sud de tokyo cube
se trouve la municipalité d'inuvik un
d'autres emplacements de choix pour la
protection du nord l'un station de
réception satellite assure de bonnes
communications et la transmission rapide
d'informations le norad il a aménagé le
de ces quatre emplacements avancé
d'opération
c'est l'installation la plus au nord
exploitée par le norad explique le maire
dino vic à peine deux ou trois personnes
travaillent pourtant ils peuvent tout de
même suivre d'ici à peu près n'importe
quoi qui s'approche du canada
poursuit-il
pour intervenir du haut des airs la
piste de l'aéroport d'innover qui a été
aménagé pour accueillir des f 18 mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait au point
ils doivent utiliser un table d'arrêt
pour atterrir parce que la piste est
encore trop court précise-t-il et quant
à la capacité de véritablement assurer
une protection du territoire le maire
soulève des inquiétudes
il faudrait être fou pour ne pas
s'inquiéter la présence militaire est
très limité dit il à la fin des années
80 les forces armées ont démontré la
base militaire qui se trouvait à inuvik
le quartier général de la force
interarmes et opérationnelles du nord se
trouve à yellowknife à plus de mille
kilomètres au sud inuvik c'est de là que
sont dirigées les opérations durent
angels s'est réservé aux milieux
éloignés qui assure une forme de
présence militaire
c'est une vaste région où il n'y a pas
de menace militaire imminente explique
le commandant du premier groupe de
patrouille canadien
assure une présence 24 sept et s'ils
voient quelque chose il leur apporte
immédiatement dit le lieutenant-colonel
raymond chiasson
pour la première ministre des
territoires du nord-ouest les
discussions sur la protection du nord
n'ont rien de nouveau mais il est bien
consciente que l'invasion que son
ukraine ravive le débat acharné est prêt
mais il ya plus que l'ukraine dit elle
avec les changements climatiques les
eaux de l'arctique seront navigable sur
une plus longue période
il faudra être prêt à y protéger nos
intérêts ajoute t-elle elle a écrit à
juste être d'eau qui s'est engagé à en
discuter avec les premiers ministres des
trois territoires
et politiquement c'est un bon moment
pour le faire plus l'environnement
international est instable plus la
pression interne dans le public plus la
volonté du public a accepté dépenses
militaires augmentent le broc indien ici
on vraiment une fenêtre d'opportunité
pour développer un argumentaire un
discours qui lui permettent de dubaï
nous on doit augmenter les dépenses
militaires et voici pourquoi
un toc toc toc ce soir la population se
sent bien loin de cette joute politique
ici comme à inuvik il importe de
démontrer sa solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien et en levant la tête vers le
ciel la lueur des aurores boréales
semble être un présage porteur d'espoir
et si valérie gamache radio canada toc
toc toc